[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est trop beau lapsus du
moins c'est ce qu'on s'imagine sauf que
parfois entre les médias et les haters
pas facile de tenir bon
de plus en plus de célébrités osent
exprimer leurs difficultés face aux
critiques et à une médiatisation parfois
très présentes c'est le cas par exemple
de l'ouanne qui a expliqué au journal le
parisien les époques qui apportent
parfois la médiatisation à partir du
moment où tu es dans la lumière tu vas
t'en prendre plein la gueule la
chanteuse évoque notamment les critiques
sur la prise de poids autour de sa
grossesse des critiques qui l'ont
parfois fait douter il ya des jours où
ça va me faire plaisir que lorsqu'il ya
des jours où je calcule même pas où j'en
ai absolument rien à faire une vie
privée exposé et commenté que la jeune
femme voudrait plus discrète mais alors
boutons se plaindre des critiques quand
on est célèbre
[Musique]
alors gilles verdez non pas comme ça
en médiatisant on peut soi-même être
triste mais le médiatiser juste pour
tous les gens qui auraient aimé être
célèbres ou qui vénère cet artiste ou
qui souffrent dans leur quotidien je
trouve ça indécent on peut passer par là
on sait depuis le départ que quand on
est connu au célèbre il va y avoir des
effets pervers qui sont que les gens
vont pouvoir vont juger si on veut pas
être jugé on n'essaie pas d'être artiste
célèbre alors à vous est-ce que vous
avez été est déjà vraiment triste un
truc qui s'est passé vous ai dit
j'aurais jamais dû faire ce métier ça va
trop loin benjamin non moi j'suis pas
pour une fois je suis d'accord avec lui
je pense que quand on est bon on fait un
métier de pour être que quand on est
connu bien évidement à prix à payer
alors on va pas se plaindre pour le coup
je comprends très bien ce que veut dire
régime après parfois ça peut faire très
mal moi j'étais une seule fois dans ma
vie j'ai été blessé par quelque chose
c'était en une de voici parce qu'on
voyait jouer avec mon fils et on
sous-entend des jeux de maltraiter mais
non voilà ce que oui j'avais en fait
l'un des barrages de l'eau encore soit
ils étaient encore là et c'est vrai que
ça m'avait blessé mais à paris c'est
quoi c'est quoi en fait je tenais mon
fils par le pied d'accord il faudrait
que j'étais en fait ivre mort
mais honnêtement quand on fait ce métier
moi mes grands parents disaient qu'il
fallait assumer le service après vente
sur ces jeux c'est une jolie formule on
fait ce métier parce qu'on est voilà on
est en et du talent on est un chanteur
ou d'un acteur et il ya des effets et
évidemment il ya un prix à payer mais se
plaindre c'est effectivement je trouve
ça un peu indécent mathieu mathieu moi
je peux tout d'accord parce que je
trouve que le le pain là la célébrité
c'est une conséquence c'est pas un objet
à l'humain donc on fait pas du tout ce
métier pour être connu fin j'ai pas que
si on n'est pas content mais à la base
quand à la télévision vraiment pour
s'amuser parce qu'on aime ce métier bien
sûr elle les conséquences ma part dont
gilles mais c'est pas parce qu'on est
con et connu qu'on érige qu'on est
forcément heureux c'est ça va pas du
tout avec ses passes et les conséquences
très dur à subir mois moi j'ai été
ajoutés dans un magazine par exemple baa
pardon
j'avais jamais dit moi que j'étais gay
un magazine people qui avait sorti et
quelques avait sorti ça
c'est toujours pareil et ça mal ça m'a
blessée parce que à ces portages était
beau coup de ma grand-mère qui kim
éduqué beaucoup avec elle le savait pas
je ne souhaite pas qu'elle le sache pas
ce que c'est une autre génération et où
voilà quoi et du coup elle était un peu
malade tout ça et les futurs une aide
soignante qui l'a amené les magazines et
on s'était arrangé pour tous planquer et
je sais que c'est leur ai fait beaucoup
de peine encore une fois parce que c'est
une personne de notre génération et tout
ça donc oui ce sont des choses qui sont
très difficiles à gérer parce que c'est
auriez préféré lui dire beaucoup ouais
ouais en tout cas oui on te dit qu'avec
pas comme ça voilà pas comme ça mais
valérie oui non mais moi je tu vois pas
où est le problème de dire que parfois
on peut être blessé j'ai dit on a le
droit de dire oui évidemment la
célébrité quand ton las il ya plein
d'avantagés où il faut le dire celui des
moments où on dit balla aujourd'hui ça
m'a fait mal on a le droit de le dire
c'est pas très grave non mais je suis
pas d'accord avec mathieu la célébrité
ça ne tombe pas sur n'importe qui il ya
plein de gens qui rêvent d'être célèbre
qui font tout pour devenir célèbre et
qui deviennent célèbres ça ces gens de
télé réalité ça c'est pas les ans il ya
plein de gens entraînés spécialement
qu'un million ou il ya malheureusement
pas beaucoup de gens qui ont du talent
c'est pas des grands artistes et
beaucoup de gens qui voulaient être
celles qui font la télévision pour qui
et ils prennent ils sont très exposés
ils reçoivent énormément de critiques et
voilà il faut l'accepter c'est la règle
du jeu et c'est ce qu'elle dit douane
elle dit que c'est extrêmement violent
mais elle accepte mais c'est différent
la critique et puis d'aider des acteurs
qui disent
qu'ils vont sortir on peut la vie rurale
guinée on n'est pas tous égaux pas
pardon mais par rapport à sa sensibilité
son parcours de vie c'est complexe et
elle en a vraiment pris plein la gueule
de manière absolument immonde et c'est
pas parce que lé célèbre qu'elle a le
droit d'être critiqué sur son physique
avec des attaques grosso fob absolument
indigne et magistrats uim accord avec
benjamin je suis pas du tout d'accord
avec gilles je trouve que c'est
absolument injuste c'est absolument
dégueulasse parce que si ça conduit un
burn-out 6 a construit sa conduit à une
dépression 6 a conduit un suicide en
gare oui mais enfin c'est le prix de la
célèbre icône un peu fragile et vous
autour de la table à votre niveau vous
avez déjà été blessées par un truc ou
par des attaques sur les réseaux mois
juillet quelqu'un qui a dit que j'avais
besoin d'un montage sous le charme
merci d'être là gilles
vous le savez très bien parce que vous
m'avez soutenu les quelques jours après
la demande en mariage ont été
extrêmement violent avec une déferlante
de commentaires après je m'en étais
expliqué ici surtout pour fatou 2 ma
responsabilité et je suis émue au moment
d'en reparler donc le prix à payer avait
été violent parce que dans ces cas là
vous déchaîner des passions est alors
encore une fois peut-être que ce que
j'ai fait était maladroit c'est pas le
problème mais le déchaînement avait été
hyper compliqué et heureusement vous
étiez là le week-end et après vous étiez
là tout le temps pour en parler parce
que vous savez pas comment gérer mais
simplement ce que se disent et les
critiques sont violents combats se
parler de la médiatisation je pense que
dans ces cas là il faut rester dans sa
coquille et pas s'arrêter au moment où
ils
n'ont j'ai pensé que j'ai pensé que
excusez moi j'ai pensé que le soutien
que vous apportiez dans ces cas là était
vraiment nécessaire pour fatou et moi il
équilibre du couple et vous savez pas à
quel point ça avait été un proche vous
savez pas à quel point ça va être
important moi
c'était compliqué parce que c'est
violent et en fait moi franchement moi
je m'en fous totalement je peux tout
prendre mon fou c'est hyper violent sur
les réseaux parfois ce que je dis je le
mérite mais c'est pour elle
pour l'entourage elle n'avait rien fait
rien demandé et c'est l'entourage qui
est dans ces cas là qui subit voilà donc
merci bernard mémoires récemment j'ai
été très violemment attaqué sur les
réseaux sociaux parce que j'ai été très
mal compris sans doute j'ai du mal à
exprimer j'avais pas l'habitude du tout
de ressorts autant de violence je reçois
que la gentillesse mais là parce que je
défends des la présomption d'innocence
parce que j'aurais dû dire que je crois
les plaignantes évidemment donc je le
redis que je défends les femmes qui sont
mal à bouger vraiment à oui parce que
quand on est mal compris c'est
l'injustice si vous voulez là du coup
vous vous lisez mal et j'ai mal vécu
j'ai vu beaucoup de choses pour ça que
j'ai bloqué les commentaires
actuellement toujours actuellement
encore mais c'est extrêmement violent
moi je moi qui défend justement ce
combat et je croit les plaignants parce
qu'il faut croire les peignant que ça
ait beaucoup évolué et heureusement et
que maintenant les écoutes et en
revanche je défends aussi la
présentation des mafieux on en parle et
c'est vrai que quand on est connu frick
fondamentale enfin gros mental
l'asim est vraiment vraiment vraiment
vraiment bon que j'arrêtais un an et je
vous ai dit bien sûr je voulais faire du
cinéma tous avantages de paris v mais il
y avait une fatigue nerveuse ça c'est
sûr ça m'a fait tellement de bien cette
année pour moi oui pal et réussi en
moins besoin d'aller après la polémique
avec le rappeur j'ai eu énormément de
moi moi comme quand bernard moi j'avais
d'habitude chez un peu bisounours moi
j'avais vraiment des flots d'amour et
tout d'un coup chez j'ai pas compris un
déferlement de 2 n 2 n y compris
antisémite etc et je m'y attendais vrai
crack et 2 ça a été vraiment très dur
vous m'avez et vous avez été d'un grand
secours d'abord il ya eu aussi même de
la violence physique qui était voilà et
j'ai même eu un garde du corps on
m'avait même journée un garde du corps
pendant quelques temps ça et c'est moi
ce qui m'a vraiment je suis un peu ému
ce qui m'a vraiment fait de la peine
c'est que ça fait de la peine à mes
parents
que j'ai en moi c'est ailleurs que
j'adore voilà ils ont eu peur pro -
ouais donc
on a encore des petites blessures quand
même un très bon c'est vrai mais je suis
très heureuse parce que vraiment les
téléspectateurs ont été absolument
adorable que hope rendre la distance et
on sait que c'est très ciblé et que
c'est une cyber attaque et que ça va
passer et bien c'était compliqué mais ce
que tout le monde sait que c'est pas
nous bien sûr nous on sait qu'on est
fort mais que c'est pas un problème on
fait de la télé c'est pas très grave
mais en revanche quand ta maman a peur
ben là c'est autre chose
dans un sacré mental c'est vrai mathieu
tu le dis c'est surtout qu'en plus en
plus entre guillemets la nouvelle
génération de tes vérités et tout ça
c'est ce que disait il en colère sur
l'autre jour ils sont nés les réseaux
sociaux ils sont nés avec jaillir cc
flot de haine et tout ça mais bernard
valérie ou même moins on n'est pas né
que les réseaux sociaux quand on a fait
ce métier on n'avait pas on n'était pas
prêts entre guillemets à ça et c'est ces
réseaux sociaux cette haine qui arrive
elle est très violente et en plus faut
quand même préciser dans ce genre
d'émission très vite on oublie les
caméras on est entre nous mais comme
dans un dîner entre potes c'est parfois
on veut faire un bon mot parce qu'on
dirait et moi je vais faire un bon mot
et la blague c'était belge du coup j'ai
répété mais c'était comment vous comment
vous diriez vous vous apprendriez à un
enfant comment on fait des enfants voilà
et j'avais dit une connerie j'avais à
propos de mon neveu mais mon neveu c'est
toute ma vie et le lendemain mais j'ai
eu un nombre de téléphoner et mon ami
fogiel qui m'a dit faut il faut que tu
fasses a démenti ce que ça part dans
tous les sens est ce un tsunami et on
sait pas comment gérer ça on n'a pas
fait ce métier pour ça on a pas d'étude
de crise on n'est pas un homme politique
on n'a pas des gens y viennent pour
gérer des crises et manga redux a
exactement les mêmes tout reproche dans
ces cas là aussi un de vraiment de vos
proches et de deux absolument
techniquement absolument l'ailé proche
de l'équipe qui est là bien sûr qu'à
l'avouer tout ça mais c'est vrai que we
say say say c'est très violent mais
regardez combien je suis désolé c'est
très très bien et et merci à tous a été
spectateur qui ont été absolument
adorable
[Applaudissements]